[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 week-end
sur tv 78 de l'actualité des idées de
sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines voici le sommaire de
ce 12 novembre
cinq sont labellisées dans les yvelines
les sites éducative avaient leurs
journées départementales cette semaine
ça se passait mercredi du côté du
nouveau collège de mantes-la-jolie
retour sur la journée avec raphaël
sodini préfet délégué pour l'égalité des
chances qui est notre invité suite et
fin de notre dossier de la rédaction
consacré aux conséquences de la hausse
des prix pour réduire cet impact des
solutions existent et notamment en
matière d'énergie dans cette édition les
conseils de l' agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat de saint quentin
en yvelines et puis comme chaque
vendredi notre sélection pour s'occuper
pendant le week-end dans les yvelines ce
sera dans la deuxième partie de cette
édition avec bien sûr bixente mayence
santisteva inquiète avec mon plateau
bonjour michel gregory ngbwa bien très
bien ça va très bien aujourd'hui
beaucoup musique mais aussi de
l'insolite avec des chevaux sur une
scène de théâtre est aussi une vache en
maillot de bain et on a hâte de voir ce
tout à l'heure et ce sera dans la suite
de ce site we can
aimé jacquet y tout de suite mon invité
c'est raphaël sodini qui est avec nous
par visioconférence bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le préfet délégué à l'égalité des
chances dans les yvelines avec vous on
va revenir sur cet événement la première
journée départementale des sites et
éducatives dans les yvelines elle se
tenait mercredi au collège innovant de
mantes-la-jolie les maires des cinq
villes labellisées par l'état ont pu
présenter leur projet au public avec au
programme conférences échanges ateliers
pourquoi organiser cette journée quels
étaient les objectifs et deux objectifs
à l'organisation de cette journée le
premier set et donner à voir ce qu'on
fait dans les yvelines en matière
d'éducation pour les jeunes dans les
quartiers prioritaires on a tenu cette
journée dans le collège innovant de
mantes la jolie qui est un écrin
formidable pour tenir ce genre
d'événement et qui montre
l'investissement du conseil
départemental en la matière et puis on a
cinq cité éducative qui fonctionne bien
dans les yvelines et donc premier
objectif c'est montrer comment elle
fonctionne et puis le deuxième objectif
c'était de leur permettre d'échanger
d'échanger des bonnes idées de
développer des projets donc c'est comme
ça qu'on a eu à un forum avec les
associations pour que chaque cité
éducative puisse connaître ce qui existe
dans le département ce qu'elles ne sont
pas encore et pour qu'elle puisse avoir
l'idée de le faire à l'avenir mais
est-ce qu'on va parler dans un instant
ce travail partenarial qui est fort dans
ces cités éducative l'important aussi là
dans cette journée vous l'avez rappelé
était qu'elles puissent échanger avec
elles puissent échanger des bonnes idées
c'est aussi important que les
différentes sites éducatifs puisse
discuter des différents projets qu'elle
mène exactement on a cinq cité éducative
à mantes-la-jolie aux mureaux attrape à
chanteloup les vignes à poissy toutes
sont construites avec leur partenariat
local et elles connaissent pas forcément
ce qu'une autre site éducatif est et
donc chaque cité éducative on a des
spécificités soient culturelles soient
sportives soient artistiques soie des
sorties soit on a énormément de choses
qui existent de l'aide aux devoirs bien
sûr pour pour les enfants des collèges
et du primaire et c'est important
qu'elles se nourrissent les unes des
autres et que finalement les bonnes
idées d une puis-je contaminé si j'ose
dire les bonnes les l'action des autres
donc c'est tout ça qu'on a essayé de
mettre en place en lien avec des grandes
associations yvelinoise qui bd la pm
exclut la compagnie des contraires des
associations qui travaillent font un
boulot formidable dans le département et
ça se déroulait donc nouveau collège de
mantes la jolie qui est situé dans le
quartier du val fourré avec une
pédagogie innovante et un système de
maisons référente un peu à la manière de
poudlard harry potter c'est une
pédagogie avec une prise en compte aussi
de tous les temps de l'enfant que ce
soit scolaire ou périscolaire ce n'était
pas anodin finalement de pouvoir
proposer cette journée au sein de ce
collège ouais parce qu'il ya une vraie
complémentarité entre la volonté du
conseil départemental d'impulser dans un
collège innovants des pratiques
pédagogiques innovantes pour les pour
les collégiens du quartier du val fourré
et la dynamique de la cité éducative qui
est aussi une dynamique dans laquelle on
essaye d'ouvrir l'école à l'ensemble des
acteurs associatifs
aux parents à l'ensemble des acteurs qui
concourent à la réussite de l'enfant
donc ces deux projets sont très
complémentaires est d'ailleurs l'un des
grands axes ou mantes la jolie pour
l'année qui vient c'est de bien inscrire
le collège innovant dans la dynamique de
la cité éducative et avec le maire a
fait le cogner on est certain d'y
parvenir on le disait cinq sites
éducatifs sont labellisées dans les
yvelines on va les voir s'afficher 80
ans au tout au niveau national
mantes-la-jolie chante ou les villes les
mureaux poissy et robes sont les villes
concernées près de quarante et un mille
quarante et un mille jeunes est de 0 à
25 ans l'objectif c'est bien sûr la
réussite de chaque enfant les pagnes ou
l'apnée pas nous y semant sur tout
chaque enfant alors le constat de départ
c'est dire que et bien selon le lieu de
naissance les origines familiales les
établissements fréquentés les chances de
réussir ne sont pas les mêmes pour
chaque enfant c'est un constat qui est
connue qu'est ce qu'apporte finalement
qu'est-ce qu'apporte de nouveau c'est ce
dispositif des sites éducatifs par
rapport à des dispositifs qui existait
déjà alors il apporte deux ou trois
choses comme vous le dites dans un
canton né dans un quartier priorités en
politique de la ville quand on fréquente
à collège dit henri plus c'est à dire un
collège qui accueille des enfants qui
viennent de milieux qui sont pas
privilégiées on a moins d'accès à la
culture - accès aux sports - d'accès aux
loisirs et moins d'accès au savoir et
donc on a une scolarité qui est souvent
plus difficile que quand on vient d'un
milieu plus privilégié la cité éducative
face à ça elle fait deux choses d'abord
elle donne des moyens
commentaire parce qu'on a besoin de
moyens supplémentaires à chacun de ces
collèges pour monter des actions
culturelles de loisirs de soutien
scolaire de partenariats avec des grands
théâtres on a par exemple un partenariat
qui va se construire entre trappe et la
comédie française donc c'est tout ça
qu'on met en place et puis elle met en
place un pilotage particulier c'est à
dire que le collège est pas tout seul
pour gérer les la cité éducative il
l'est on associe au collège les équipes
de la de la municipalité les équipes du
maire et des équipes du préfet en charge
de la politique de la ville donc mes
équipes et tous ensemble on essaye de
construire un écosystème qui permet aux
enfants d'avoir des projets adaptés à
leurs besoins et c'est vraiment une
dynamique et nouvelles qui a deux ans
sur le département des yvelines dont qui
est très récente qui a été lancé par ce
gouvernement mais qui fonctionne bien on
a cinq cité éducative et on candidate
pour quatre nouvelles cités à la fin de
l'année parce qu'on croit vraiment à ce
modèle qui produit déjà je crois de bons
résultats mais parce que d'ici la fin
2021 en a 46 au niveau national qui vont
être labellisées vous le dites dans les
yvelines peut-être de nouvelles aussi
cité éducative en tout cas elles ont
monté des dossiers
voilà qui assure on a monté quatre
dossiers nouveau pour nantes la ville
limay plaisir et sartrouville bon quatre
dossiers il ya 46 places alors on est on
sait que ça va être compliqué de tous
ses avoirs mais on se bat parce qu'on
croit vraiment à ce modèle et parce que
je trouve que c'est un modèle qui permet
de compenser les inégalités de naissance
en offrant aux enfants des quartiers 1
un écosystème beaucoup plus favorable
pour l'heure pour leur éducation avec
des partenariats très riche avec une
vraie dynamique et avec des moyens
supplémentaires parce que rien ne se
fait sans moyens supplémentaires donc on
est on est optimiste et je trouve que ça
a été une très belle journée qui s'est
finit d'ailleurs par deux petits
spectacles de la grande panne idées
contraires et la pm est ce qu on a vu
vraiment que non seulement dans nos
quartiers on a des on a des associations
dynamiques mais on a aussi de
l'excellence des comédiens qui jouent
merveilleusement des jeunes qui chante
merveilleusement et tout ça c'est
important de le dire dans ces temps on
doute parfois de nous mêmes c'est
important de montrer que dans nos
quartiers on a vraiment de l'excellence
et de la réussite donc il y en aura
d'autres les journées départementales
il est éducative on va pas les faire
toutes les semaines puisque je serai un
peu lourd mais on a les dc d'ici un an
ou deux ans sans doute on va essayer
d'en refaire d'autres c'est aussi un
moment je veux le souligner un peu
important de se retrouver après ce temps
pandémique on s'est retrouvés uniquement
par visio alors là je vous retrouve par
visio jeu je tiens mes promesses mais là
se retrouver à 200 dans un sac masqué et
avec le contrôle du pass sanitaire mais
voilà sur se voir en vrai c'était aussi
un moment important cette année qui a
été un peu un peu difficile merci
raphaël soit disent avoir été avec nous
je vous en prie les faits délégué à
l'égalité des chances dans les yvelines
le dernier épisode à présent du dossier
de la rédaction toute cette semaine tv
60,18 s'intéresser à l'impact de la
hausse des prix sur les yvelinois après
le constat voici deux premières
solutions on vous en donne avec des
conseils pour faire baisser la facture
avec l' agence locale de l'énergie et du
climat de saint quentin en yvelines un
reportage de céline charles et de
bixente mais rien senti steban le
constat est sans appel la flambée des
prix de l'énergie est préoccupante et
elle commence à peser sur le budget des
français le prix du gaz et de
l'électricité ne cesse d'augmenter
depuis de nombreuses années il a doublé
en dix ans pour le prix du gaz et a
connu une hausse de 50 % pour
l'électricité sur la même période que la
ministre avait parlé en 70 d'une hausse
autour de 12% est en fait le bouclier
tarifaire qui a été mise en place par le
par le gouvernement va limiter cette
hausse à 4 % mais on est quand même dans
une tendance haussière sur les années
futures
face à cela l'aide de saint quentin en
yvelines implantée à montigny le
bretonneux propose des solutions
notamment au niveau des travaux de
rénovation énergétique
la structure met en avant une démarche
dite de type négawatt c'est vraiment
d'aller vers une économie zéro carbone
mais qui s'axe sur trois principal
levier d'abord la sobriété c'est à dire
consommer l'énergie uniquement là où
elle est nécessaire ne pas gaspiller
l'énergie l'efficacité avoir des
équipements qui fonctionnent bien voilà
se chauffer
la chaudière va rendre ce service
m'avoir une chaudière qui est efficace
et qui ne gâche pas de l'énergie et
ensuite essayer de développer au maximum
les énergies renouvelables pour produire
cette énergie l'énergie la moins chère
c'est celle qu'on ne consomme pas déjà
donc au niveau des des travaux qu'on
peut faire ça va être des travaux
d'isolation thermique de changement
d'équipements vétustes de vieilles
chaudières vieux radiateurs à deux
changements de vitrages l'association
sensibilise également aux éco gestes des
changements d'habitudes simple et du
quotidien qui tendent à limiter la
hausse de consommation réduire d'un
degré la température de consigne du
thermostat on va pouvoir faire autour de
7 % d'économies
ensuite bien régler la température de
son frigo vanot essayer de faire à 4
degrés 4° minimum voilà on va pouvoir
économiser et également vérifié au
niveau du congélateur qu'on n'a pas trop
de givre dès qu'on a dû vivre ça à faire
des surconsommations l'alec réalise sur
rendez-vous des bilans thermiques
propose des améliorations et oriente
vers des professionnels des initiatives
bienvenues pour freiner la hausse de
l'énergie
et puis votre rubrique est légal
checking pour décrypter l'actualité
analysée le vrai du faux vincent
couronne du collectif des surligneurs
vous êtes aujourd'hui à y voir plus
clair conseil de l'europe conseil
européen de termes très proches mais des
instances complètement différentes
pompes lui faire l'erreur regarder
ces derniers jours le conseil de
l'europe a fait circuler sur les réseaux
sociaux une campagne visant à promouvoir
la tolérance et qui faisait incidemment
la promotion du voile islamique comme
élément de liberté de la femme une
campagne rapidement dénoncé par divers
partis politiques et responsables
associatifs et finalement retiré des
réseaux sociaux par le conseil de
l'europe une campagne au surpluss
cofinancé par l'union européenne il n'en
fallait pas plus pour que sur les
plateaux télé et les réseaux sociaux la
plus grande confusion se répandent sur
qui avait fait quoi et qu'on mélange
conseil de l'europe des conseils
européens alors une bonne fois pour
toutes comment ne plus faire la
confusion le conseil de l'europe est une
organisation internationale créée en
1949 dont l'objectif est de promouvoir
la paix et la démocratie très vite de
nombreux états vont rejoindre ce conseil
de l'europe dont l'action va se
développer avant tout dans la protection
des droits de l'homme aujourd'hui 47
états en sont membres du portugal à la
russie du royaume-uni à la turquie c'est
le conseil de l'europe notamment qui
établit la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme le conseil européen
lui n'est pas une organisation
internationale c'est une institution de
l'union européenne qui réunit les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement mais alors
pourquoi avoir deux appellations aussi
proche la faute revient si l'on peut
dire à valéry giscard d'estaing qui
contre l'avis de ses partenaires chef de
gouvernement lance lors de sa conférence
de presse qui clôture le sommet de
décembre 1974 1 nous avons participé au
premier conseil européen ce conseil
européen réuni donc les membres de
l'union européenne ils sont 27 alors une
bonne fois pour toutes
comment ne plus faire la confusion le
conseil de l'europe avec un grand e
c'est pour la grande europe à 47 le
conseil européen avec un petit c'est
pour la petite europe à vingt-sept vous
n'avez plus d'excusé désormais pour
faire l'erreur
allez c'est l'heure de vous donner
l'envié de sortir dans ce statut ce week
end
avec bien sûr la sélection de bixente
mais rien senti stevan kg est revenu en
plateau dans un instant bixente votre
invité et qui était également qui est
également avec nous en plateau et vous
commencez fort pour cette partie loisirs
avec un voyage dans le temps oui un
spectacle de grande dimension et ça
tombe bien dans la grande salle du chêne
et rocquencourt l'odyssey du temps c'est
plus d'une vingtaine d'artistes des
scènes de combat de la musique un écran
géant et même deux chevaux
représentations samedi à 20h30 et
dimanche à 15 heures voici ce qui vous
attend
c'est l'histoire de florent un jeune
dépressif qui va consulter son
psychothérapeute sans savoir que tous
deux vont explorer et re vivre de
nombreuses aventures à travers les
époques ce spectacle a été écrit à
partir de transcription de vraies
régressions ce qu'on appelle des
régressions dans des vies antérieures
donc une technique
de psychothérapie qui va chercher dans
le passé du patient d'un enfer en fait
dans la mémoire du patient c'est ses
traumas de façon à les rendre à la
conscience et de résoudre ses problèmes
psychologiques l'odyssée du temps de la
grande scène du chéné rocancourt c'est
une vingtaine de comédiens cascadeurs
musiciens et même deux chevaux ça va
au-delà de ce que je pensais
un spectacle très spectaculaire c'est
sans jeu de mots mêmes essais
époustouflants c'est une série de ce
qu'on appelle en
spectacle aussi un c'est une série de
tours de force donc chaque chaque
tableau chaque époque était est un tour
de force je pense que les gens vont bien
rigoler et s'attacher à chaque
personnage chaque personnage est
attachant et chaque univers est unique
en plus d'être tenues et maquillage le
choix de faire jouer la musique
directement sur scène pour plus
d'immersion ça ramène caraman les
époques parce que le son des instruments
nous transporte tout de suite dans la
bonne époque est comme ça ça simplifie
aussi pour le spectateur
la lecture des tableaux un spectacle qui
voit grand et qui n'a pas fait peur à la
grande scène déjà prêtes à l'accueillir
c'est un spectacle qui vient au bout de
dix ans d'histoire en fait on peut se
permettre de le faire et les contraintes
c'est bien sûr des contraintes
techniques avec des choses particulières
s'il ya des cascades il ya quand même
des armes à feu il ya des projections
vidéo projection en rétro
rétroprojection assez particulière et
puis à beaucoup de monde sur scène
évidemment ça demande du monde et ça
demande beaucoup d'expertisé beaucoup de
répétitions 800 personnes sont attendues
pour venir voir les deux représentations
samedi 13 novembre à 20h30 et dimanche
14 à 15 heures
pour continuer bixente ce n'est pas vous
qui allez vous mettre en maillot de bain
vous allez me dire vu les températures
du moment mieux vaut éviter mais bel et
bien une vache exactement grégory la
nouvelle médiathèque de carrières sous
poissy accueille ce samedi 13 novembre
l'auteur compositeur interprète laurent
tout seul pour un concert justement de
son album la vache en maillot de bain
c'est l'interview express
bonjour je m'appelle laurent tout seul
je suis auteur compositeur interprète de
chansons jeune public
ce week-end en effet il ya un concert à
carrières sous poissy à la médiathèque à
la nouvelle médiathèque voilà et donc
il ya un concert qui est prévu à 10
heures mais comme il y as énormément de
réservation du coup il y aura un
deuxième concert à 11h15
j'ai sorti un album mais je montre qui
s'appelle la vache en maillot de bain
c'est une de mes copines d'ailleurs et
donc c'est marche tellement bien auprès
des enfants en normandie que du coup du
coup j'ai demandé à un dessinateur de bd
de me faire une bande dessinée sur la
vache en maillot de bain
[Musique]
pour résumer ce sont les animaux d'une
ferme qui au final ils s'aperçoivent que
que leurs fermiers travail pour rien et
donc il décide de prendre des vacanciers
[Musique]
/
le but pour les enfants c'est vraiment
de les faire chanter de les faire taper
des mains enfin voilà de participer au
maximum
[Musique]
la guitare joe cole et des cases ou
guimbarde harmonica fin il ya vraiment
pas mal pas mal de deux d'instruments à
montrer je n'ai pas réussi la dernière
fois à vous faire chanter un air de lady
gaga
là la vache en maillot de bain ça te
laisser les cieux volé une vache en
maillot de bain un mouton en caleçon
bravo
formant ce musical hors de la musique
toujours je le disais tout à l'heure il
ya votre invité qui nous a rejoint un
plateau c'est le capitaine jean louis
delage oui en effet c'est décidément un
journal riche en rythmes et en arpèges
jean-louis delage bienvenue vous êtes le
maître à la baguette de l'orchestré des
pompiers des yvelines grégory d'ailleurs
on est ce qu'on peut avoir une petite
présentation de l'eau dsp y kim bien sûr
l'orchestré départemental des sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines a été créée en
1987 il était à l'origine une batterie
fanfare il s'est élargi en orchestre
harmonique dès 1995 il est dirigé par le
capitaine jean louis delage qui était
avec moi en plateau est aussi l'adjudant
fabien lacoste il est composé de 55
musiciens de haut niveau tous vêtus aux
couleurs des sapeurs pompiers la
vocation de cet orchestre est
d'accompagner les cérémonies officielles
commémorative ou festives mais
l'orchestré donne aussi des concerts
comme l'événement dont on va parler en
somme il fait partie intégrante du
patrimoine musical du département c'est
exact must de la ville a bien travaillé
et il a très bien travaillé je vous
remercie vous êtes ici du coup parce que
vous jouez samedi prochain le 20
novembre pour l'événement sous le thème
d'une soirée à bretenoux et le début de
la soirée est à 20h30 au théâtre
alexandre dumas de saint-germain-en-laye
un lieu que vous connaissez puisque vous
étiez déjà venu en 2019 si je me trompe
pas c'était le 9 novembre pour un
événement similaire quel est le
programme cette fois alors le programme
cette année et autour de la musique
américaine pour une raison simple c'est
que nous avons un partenariat depuis 20
ans partenariat amical entre les
pompiers de new york et pompiers des
yvelines et cette année on a le
malheureusement le triste anniversaire
des 20 ans du wall trade center donc on
a choisi et en plus une convention
signée entre les pompiers de new york et
les pompiers les yvelines donc on s'est
dit on va orienter tout le programme
autour de la musique américaine et la
musique composée aux états unis vous
prenez une soirée haute en surprises on
peut extirper un avant goût d'une
d'entre elles sans trop spoiler tout à
fait alors dans la partie qui sera relié
à une petite partie du de dix minutes
qui sera réservé vraiment en hommage aux
pompiers américains à 343 pompiers qui
sont décédées le 11 septembre
on fera intervenir des cornemuses sur le
thème du film wall trade center d'accord
et pour revenir du coup sûr votre or
qu'est-ce vous nous avez habitués à
jouer des musiques très connu du grand
public je pense à star wars spider man
ou encore les simpson voici d'ailleurs
un petit extrait
[Musique]
cette fois donc c'est au tour des états
unis du xxème siècle qu'est ce qui nous
attend comme alors on a programmé west
side story mission impossible
un américain à paris alors de gershwin
c'est l'américain qui découvrent des
différentes sonorités des grands
boulevards
les musiques de film captain america les
indestructibles de musique aussi très
abordable pour le plus jeune public il
ya aussi du 21e siècle du coup du doigt
la le concert dure combien de temps ces
deux partis de 40 minutes avec un
entracte d'accord et ce concert doc est
donné au profit des orphelins de sapeurs
pompiers il y en a plus de 700 en france
l'entrée gratuite ça se fait sous forme
de ton à la sortie en fait tout à fait
alors aujourd'hui bien entendu quand je
suis arrivé à une vingtaine d'années
chez les pompiers y avait 700 orphelins
aujourd'hui on est proche des 1500
1490 exactement et depuis également une
vingtaine d'années on enregistre des cds
dont les bénéfices de 2 des ventes qui
sont décernées à ses orphelins et là on
a décidé de faire la soirée complète
pour eux ce qui veut dire que il n'y a
pas de prix d'entrée mais à la sortie il
y aura deux urnes sur lesquels le public
du programme d'aidé dont justement
j'allais y venir pour finir vous
enregistrez justement que vous visitez
céder une partie reversés aux enfants
orphelins il y en aura un autour du
concert sur la thématique de broadway
vous avez prévu alors il ya pas le thème
de broadway et sera probablement
enregistre au printemps on va profiter
du premier trimestre 2011 22 pour
enregistrer ce c'est m mais on a
plusieurs propositions notamment un
double cd autour du jazz qui touche
complètement les états unis parce que
c'était surtout le swing et les les
années
d'après guerre donc il est complètement
dans le thème également et puis on a une
dizaine de cd de toute façon à proposer
au public merci beaucoup jean-louis
delage d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
donc vous êtes le chef d'orchestre de
départementale des sapeurs pompiers des
yvelines vous donner un concert ce 20
novembre prochain au théâtre alexandre
dumas de saint-germain-en-laye un
événement sous le thème une soirée a
bredouillé donc save qui débute à 20h30
et on attend les yvelinois nombreux pour
faire la fête et aussi se mobiliser au
profit des orphelins de sapeurs pompiers
il ya un numéro de téléphone qui
pourrait s'afficher voilà il va
s'afficher pour toute information
réservation aussi autour de ce concert
merci capitaine d'avoir été avec en
plateau on va désormais se projeter sur
le week-end prochain on en a déjà un peu
parlé avec bien sûr ce concert puisque
l'ambition du 7-8 week-end c'est de
parler du week-end qui nous concerne
mais aussi de se projeter sur le week
end après on commence aussi avec une
compétition de cinéma après la musique
le cinéma c'est le festival les images
vagabonde qui revient pour une 10e
édition vendredi 19 novembre neuf courts
métrages seront diffusés à partir de 20h
ça va d'une animation d'une minute
attention nous à des courts métrages de
15 19 minutes pour la réalisation de
benjamin bonnet sonné après minuit un
prix du jury professionnel sera remis
mais aussi un prix du public n'hésitez
pas à vous y rendre donc pour voter pour
le petit film qui vous aura a le plus
séduit c'est l'occasion de découvrir
aussi de jeunes talents du cinéma un
rendez vous donc à l'espace maurice
béjart à verneuil-sur-seine vendredi 19
novembre à 20 heures elle aussi est elle
affiche en ce moment au cinéma la
comédienne et humoriste virgin glock à
voir aussi sur les planches mais s'il ne
vous n'avez pas eu l'occasion de voir de
la voir dans le film à l'humour limite
limite de fabrice éboué barback
l'actrice belge également humoristes se
produit au cosec pablo neruda des
mureaux un spectacle autobiographique
appelé virgin york ou presque où elle
dépend sa vie de son enfance à sa future
vieillesse la sénilité qu'elle souhaite
à tout prix éviter c'est dimanche 21
novembre à 17h30 pour réserver rendez
vous sur le site internet de la commune
des mureaux les tarifs sont compris
entre 12 et 29 euros et on termine
bixente avec un spectacle à voir en
famille et ce à partir du week-end
prochain oui dimanche commence la balade
d'automne des 400 coups le pôle jeune
public de vallée de seine a prévu huit
spectacles vivants dont deux
spécialement pour les scolaires donc
théâtre musique compte c'est pour tous
les âges et ça se déroule dans la vallée
de seine du 21 novembre au 5 décembre
faute de temps grégory parce que je suis
pressé de partir en week-end aussi pour
tout ce que je vous ai annoncé la
semaine dernière
je ne vais pas vous donner je veux
donner qu'un top 2 2 ce qui me tente à
titre personnel ça vous convient allez
moi je débuterai donc à mantes la jolie
le mercredi 24 novembre à 15 heures si
le chef accepte mes heures de
récupération bien sûr un pour écouter le
concert de soul béton qui s'appelle
panique au bois béton un spectacle
festif de funk hip hop de la musique
urbaine comme on les aime si j'arrive
pas à libérer pas de panique je me
rattraperai le samedi 27 puisqu'il donne
un second concert à 17 heures ensuite je
me rendrai bien aussi le mercredi 1er
décembre à 15 heures au théâtre simone
signoret de mantes la ville pour
assister au show du trio du moustache
poésie club ça mix entre humour rap hip
hop qui parlent du quotidien d'un petit
écolier finalement et allégories je vous
laisse pas en rade un si ça vous a pas
inspiré vous avez quatre autres
spectacles à les voir toutes les
informations sont sur le site internet
des 400 coups kwame chargé merci bixente
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission le
7-8 week-end on se retrouve bien sûr
vendredi prochain entre temps il ya le
retour du journal ne manquez pas le
retour du journal de la rédaction est du
lundi au vendredi sur tv 78 et d'ici là
passez un excellent week-end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]